[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
que celui ici qui n'a jamais écrite et
d'écoles qui n'a jamais critiqué l'école
se lève maintenant ou se taise à jamais
faut pas bien avec projecteurs mais je
pense que ceci m'a été envoyé par un
enseignant qui a qui arrêtent et enfin
qui a fait une pause carrière fin qui a
mis de côté sa carrière d'enseignant ya
20 ans eli est revenue l'année dernière
et et il m'a dit john cette incroyable
20 ans je retrouve exactement l'écho
dans l'état où je les quitte et rien n'a
changé alors que la société autour a
énormément changé et d'écarts entre
l'école et la société devenu abyssal
si bien que ça génère beaucoup de
tension et de souffrance par exemple ici
à la place des élèves on pourrait écrire
enseignants et donc ça se reflète aussi
de notre score pisa par exemple qui ne
fait pas sourire
alors que peut-on faire est ce une
fatalité
et donc après le parcours que qui vient
d'être expliqué g j'étais amené à faire
beaucoup de conférences notamment avec
des enseignantes dans la salle et
j'étais très frustré parce que le lundi
matin après la conférence de retour en
classe rien de changé et je me suis dit
comment peut-on faire quand j'ai été
voir en classe avec ses enseignants et
leurs élèves et j'ai d'abord observer et
puis j'ai donné de conseils et puis j'ai
transformé des classes en deux heures
toujours un temps suivant le même schéma
que ce soit dans le connecticut où
athènes avec beaucoup de succès mais
avec une autre frustration alors qu'elle
me dit pour une ville d'un million
d'habitants pour visiter toutes les
classes il faudra environ 10 ans en plus
qui dirait que ces classes sont
demandeuses puisque ils n'ont pas pu
voir ou sentir je dirais le changement
que leur
pause et cela que j'ai créé un
laboratoire européen d'innovation
pédagogique qui prend la forme d'une
petite école qui a ouvert il ya deux
mois et qui est visitable par les
équipes d'enseignants justement alors
ici ces sept avant le début des cours le
briefing briefing commence à 8h30 et
c'est l'occasion de remplir son journal
de classe c'est à dire que les étudiants
vont charger eux-mêmes
que vont ils faire quels tests vont ils
réussir aujourd'hui si l'on présente
jalil qui va faire de l'histoire
alors prêt ça ils ont une heure de
travail autonome individuel ici nous
avons victoria qui s'occupe de la
réception de l'école les élèves gère
l'école donc elle répond au téléphone et
vous ne vous la porte etc
je parlais de nettoyer les toilettes en
toscane blague donc moi le premier je
dois montrer l'exemple
si le directeur peut le faire tout le
monde peut le faire alors les aînés sont
très actifs ici ils sont fatigués les
parents nous rapportent qu'ils sont très
fatigués en fin de journée quand il
rentre à la maison tout comme fanny et
où la chaleur je vous assure on et ça
fait deux mois on est très très fatiguée
et je me demande même mais qu'est ce que
je fais ici à devenir une conférence ted
alors que je devrais être avec fanny à
l'école en train de préparer les
améliorations de la semaine prochaine la
ceiba kita qui prépare qui va assister
fanni pour une son histoire l'histoire
avec un jeu de cartes qui a été créé
avec les étudiants
donc là je les prends l'improviste au
début de la leçon mais on veut être sûr
que fanny monde parle pas trop longtemps
parce que si on laisse faire on a
tendance à parler deux heures donc les
élèves nous mettre un petit timer co
comme ceux ci de 15 minutes pour être
sûr que ça dure que 15 minutes
d'ailleurs je vois que vous aussi vous
ma vie ma timer une mère ce qui reste
catherine rose
merci si on est à la fin avec 15 minutes
il n'y a pas de son fait dans la vidéo
et après l'enseignant 120 fanny 120 les
élèves prennent une photo des cartes
telles qu'elles sont et puis ils
collaborent entre eux
en fait chaque élève reçoit beaucoup de
petits cours particuliers chaque jour je
sens le son qui devrait venir
pendant ce temps les autres élèves
avaient continué à travailler jeune
homme soit individuel soit collaboratif
alors je me suis beaucoup intéressé à la
recherche scientifique dédié de neuf des
dix dernières années son influence des
arts martiaux traditionnels sur les
résultats scolaires et en fait c'est une
influence énorme
par exemple ici je vais leur faire
exercer leur métacognition s'observer et
voir ce qu'ils font est juste ou pas lu
ce fameux temps ou alors le contrôle
inhibiteur donc il faut qu'il quitte
l'immédiateté pour arrive à penser
finement pôle hémato si je veux m haies
ça je les mange non je peux pas pourquoi
contrôle inhibiteur là nous avons lucile
qui est une responsable de groupe
la 14 ans et d'un petit groupe de 6 à 18
ans la saison pardon pour elle est en
fait c'est pas forcément la plus âgée
qui est chef qui est responsable du
groupe quoique vous le vivez dans votre
vie professionnelle aussi c'est pas
forcément le plus âgé que le meilleur
responsables de groupes sachant que
expliqué est une merveilleuse manière
d'apprendre qui a plus le besoin
d'expliquer l'élève ou le prof
donc les élèves ont souvent l'occasion
d'expliquer est comme ça d'entraîner
leurs compétences scolaires
ça c'est une vidéo que j'ai piqué un
élève en fait ils ce test il se filme
pour pour pour leurs tests qu'ils
m'envoient on les regarde ensemble pour
voir s'ils ont réussi avec quelques avec
quels critères ils font ça pour le
français par exemple il
si donc serait d'après avec elle je vois
que son poème admis par exemple il ya
aussi beaucoup de tests à pied
évidemment et lorsqu'un test est réussi
ils ont un petit cachet verts dans leur
jauge de progression une jauge un peu
comme un jeu vidéo
alors ça c'est ce que vous avez vu sur
la vidéo en fait et chaque point et
disruptif en tant que tel par rapport
une école traditionnelle mais on n'a
rien inventé et batch de 'future' tous
ces vieux vieux vin chaque point est
vieux comme le monde
prenez trois points au hasard ça devient
compliqué de trouver une école dans les
alentours qui cumule ces trois points
dans la même école je ne pense pas qu'il
existe au monde une école qui est face
tout tous qu'ils fassent tous les points
si vous vous en connaissez une contactez
moi je prends l'avion demain à gauche
sur les points que nous avons déjà
implémenté avec succès depuis deux mois
à droite
nous sommes encore en chemin par exemple
les parents n'ont aucun secours de notre
éducation en deux mois et la gestion par
les élèves n'est que partielle il gère
les paiements mais pas encore les
commandes fournisseurs par exemple aussi
dire qu'il ya moins d'enseignants par
élève même si accompagné moi c'est un
peu mentir parce que on travaille 14
heures par jour donc c'est de la triche
alors si on veut théorisé cela ça
commence par le changement de posture de
l'enseignant c'est la pierre angulaire
c'est le noeud de la transformation si
le prof n'explique plus d'où viennent
les explications alors et le mot sapiens
en être qui adore apprendre socialement
par les pairs ben les élèves n'ont pas
très tendre souvent tendance à aller
vraiment sur internet où aller dans les
livres il préfère d'abord demandé à
leurs camarades à l'école du dialogue
celui qui dialoguent pas j'ai foutu dans
une école traditionnelle on met le focus
sur les moyens cours de maths deuxième
heure le mardi tel local tu vas telle
bande à ses côtés de henri tu prends
tout manuel page 69 qui fait l'exercice
ça c'est être directif sur les moyens si
on veut libérer et délaissent les moyens
il faut être quatre ans des objectifs
chapitre 8 yens centaine d'équations en
deux inconnus dedans je veux reprendre
10 au hasard à chaque fois que tu fais
des gens prendraient 10 aux trois arts
et tu dois réussir avec 80 % parce que
honnêtement ça intéresse quelqu'un
essayait de réussir avec juste 50% faut
pas bien être lui même et je pose que
peut-être l'un ou l'autre
alors on peut poser une question plus
gênantes est-ce que vos enfants dans
leur école ça t'intéresse de réussir
avec juste 50%
moi j'en ai au moins où il va dire oui
donc c'est ça aussi qu'on essaie de
remuscler chercher chez les enfants
notamment via l'erreur instructif il
fait une erreur n'est pas une faute la
manière normale naturelle d'apprendre
quand ils passent un test quand l'élève
passe un test en fait d une satisfaction
aussi du feedback immédiat c'est à dire
que il a les réponses utiles je vais pas
reprendre sa copie et la vivre entre
deux jours après je corrige directement
un autre élève corrige directement donc
on a assez vite une des élèves qui nous
ont supplié d'avoir des interros même
durant leur récré on a dû mettre des
règles en place pour qu'ils aient plus
la file devant notre bureau d'élèves qui
veulent passer un test ça nous amène à
au fait que l'élève devient pilote
finalement de sa formation
la contrôlabilité ce qui va nourrir
finalement sa motivation intrinsèque
je suis pas motivé pour des points ni
pour de l'argent ni parce que de la
maîtresse va me sourire je suis motivé
parce que j'aime apprendre que je veux
me dépasser
mais tout ça doit être nourrie par
l'excellence par un sentiment d'urgence
en fait on est une surprise vendredi
dernier les élèves nous ont plusieurs
élèves nous ont fait une demande claire
ils nous ont dit ceci
anoh a scotché parce que quand on parle
de maths avec son camarade on peut vite
être amenés à parler de vacances donc ça
pas de pression on prend on prend tout
son temps quand on est pilote très bien
alors pourquoi faire tout cela pour moi
il ya deux raisons et d'abord les
performances académiques et aussi les
performances émotionnel des élèves que
j'aime beaucoup faire faire évoluer
alors j'aurais pu vous distribuez
peuvent mance académique prendre le cas
de la lèvre en grande difficulté
scolaire qu'il ya des échecs m'a pas mal
avec au dialogue qui sont inscrits suite
à cela mais j'ai l'impression que dans
dans ce pays
c'est devenu la norme quand je rencontre
un adolescent qui me dit moi j'ai jamais
redoublé je dis quoi tu n'as jamais
redoublé vous toi t'es pas normal et
donc je voulais prendre un autre exemple
aussi de problèmes et de musculation et
pas forcément au niveau académique
si on prend lucile qui est responsable
de groupe que nous avons vu sur la vidéo
avec ses lunettes
je pense qu'elle est dans la venue ici
avec sa maman et je pense être une bonne
idée de l'accueillir pour un témoignage
alors tout d'abord qu'est ce qui t'a
inciter à s'inscrire à l'écho du
dialogue alors que c'était pas visitable
c'était juste des bureaux vides à une
belle idée en fait ça fait nouveau
véhicule
donc je ne sais j'étais à l'école et
j'avais un problème à la fin de l'année
on a dû faire un point parce que j'avais
déjà sauté une classe donc ça c'est à
l'école traditionnelle j'étais avant
c'est ça et donc j'avais déjà sauté une
classe gt en immersion je faisais du
latin en fait je faisais plein de choses
mais je m'ennuyais énormément pour faire
ressentir un peu ce que ça fait
s'ennuyer en cours parce qu'on est
rapide
vous connaissez tous la salle d'attentes
chez le médecin et imaginez maintenant
que vous attendez six heures par jour
dans la salle d'attenté on vous dit ok
maintenant tu attendras dans sept salles
d'attentes toute l'année 6 heures et tu
devras attendre encore quatre ans donc
quand j'ai vu les cols du dialogue qu'on
peut aller à son rythme qu'on apprenait
plein de choses et j'ai bien entendu
dire dit oui parce que pressé dans une
salle d'attenté c'est pas donné à tout
le monde ça s'essouffle académique sur
le plan plus relationnel
nous t'avons nommé responsable de groupe
qu'est ce que ça implique pour toi bon
déjà le rôle du responsable de groupe
c'est en fait de maintenir un climat de
krav de travail en bref est aussi en
deux dans un deuxième plan d'être un
intermédiaire entre les élèves et fanny
et john en gros on a un peu d agent
double infiltré chez élèves pour
améliorer le système dans lequel sont
les élèves
sympa mais il a bien sûr quelques
difficultés
comme on a quelqu'un qui doit cadrer des
élèves déjà que les élèves notre
n'accepte pas l'autorité d'un professeur
de base alors accepter l'autorité d'une
fille haute de trois pommes main et qui
ressemble à hermione granger ça passe
pas facilement
puis on va prendre une petite anecdote
ah oui j'oubliais dire quelque chose il
faut aussi apprendre la communication
non-violente surtout quand on a l'âme on
tarde qui montent facilement sonné et
c'est assez compliqué j'ai même une
blessure de guerre là bon passons pour
une petite anecdote j'avais un garçon
dans mon gros donc un groupe on est sept
cloches il avait 15 ans et donc on
faisait le journal de classe ça veut
dire qu'on programmé notre journée en
quelque sorte et il me ramenait un
journal de classe avec la mauvaise
couleur raturé pas complet enfin tout ce
qu'il fallait pas faire quoi et pendant
deux semaines j'ai dû recadrer et lui
dire non il faut que tu fasses ça
il est revenu une fois cette fois chez
moi donc ce n'était pas évident pour
bosser mais au bout de deux semaines il
arrivait que son journal de classe et
j'étais complètement bluffé parce qu'il
m'avait fait le meilleur journal de
classe de tout le cros donc smiley merci
beaucoup
ils restent ici je crois que cela peut
être évident pour toi je t'ai déjà été
ramassés en pleurs dans une salle de
réunion au niveau émotionnel sat
apporter quelque chose où ça a été
surtout des difficultés
un but que les élèves vont pas forcément
du respect pour quelqu'un qui lé cad qui
est plus jeune que ça c'est compliqué
emotionnellement mai
on essaye de gérer vos tu peux rester
ici dans ses objectifs du mois de
novembre
est ce qu'on peut lui mettre un cachet
sur donné une conférence ted
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors en guise de conclusion à une reste
une minute 53 ce pas normal ne s'aggrave
en guise de conclusion en fait ce projet
a eu énormément d'intérêt de l'extérieur
d'école extérieur en fait nous sommes
même devenu le coordinateur d'un
programme européen de type erasmus plus
pour avec la norvège italie et la grèce
et des des écoles justement à se
transformer des écoles traditionnelles à
se transformer on a eu aussi un soutien
local extraordinaire je veux dire en
termes de bénévoles de volontaires qui
sont venus nous aider par exemple et
donc on pourrait presque écrire école du
dialogue projet soutenu par l'univers et
c'était extrêmement gratifiant pour tous
les élèves pour tous pour tous ceux qui
sont impliqués au niveau de l'école et
donc mais c'est vraiment épuisant donc
je suis prudent dans les demandes
maintenant que j'adresse à l'univers
parce que être exaucé c'est vraiment
très fatigant alors j'ai juste souhaiter
deux choses d'abord plus de performances
et plus de bienveillance finalement de
bonheur à l'école on peut transformer
une classe une école c'est possible
c'est rapide même ça a changé
jeudi 6 6 info profs comme moi et une
folle dingue comme fanny que j'ai vu sur
les vidéos peuvent le faire lors
imaginer ce que l'équipe de
professionnels de l'école de vos enfants
pourraient accomplir ça a changé ma vie
celle de fanny aussi en tant que prof ça
a changé la vie de nos élèves de leur
famille aussi pour le soir pour les
devoirs par exemple j'espère que ça
pourra un jour changer là votre jour
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]